A question I get asked all the time is
"Luca how can they speak better and more
confidently and faster?" and the simple
reply is: in order to speak well, you have
to speak you have to get into the habit
of speaking regularly. And there are
many ways, and many circumstances and many
people you can talk to, but one very
efficient thing that you can do - and you
can do it directly at your place if you
have an internet connection and a nice
computer - is simply to have a language
exchange. So what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to show you a few but
extremely important and efficient
things to keep in mind to have a
fantastic language change and remember
there's always a final super cool tip at
the end of the video, so stay here until
the end. If you want to create a great
sustainable efficient routine for
language exchange, the first step that
you have to do is make decisions. Take a
piece of paper and write down WHY you
want to do this. It has to be clear to
you and WHEN. Put a starting date and
tell yourself "from this moment on I'm
going to start taking language exchanges
every single week". Maybe you find
yourself in some parts of the world
where meeting people and talking to them
face-to-face is kind of problematic
especially if you're looking for foreigners
or maybe you do live in a cosmopolitan
city where there's a chance of meeting a
lot of people but you simply don't want
to and you want to be at the comfort of
your own place and talk through Skype or
through the Internet in general. So the
next thing you want to do is to find
platforms where you can find native
speakers to talk to, and as usual, the
internet offers a deluge, a wealth of
possibilities but here's the thing: the
problem is that there are so many
platforms that offer the service that
it's difficult to choose a good one so
make sure that you invest the time and
find one good platform that you like,
be it because it's user friendly, be it
because you like it visually, the
important thing is you find just one and
use that, and possibly move on
to another one oh and by the way in the
description box you will find a list of
platforms that I have used or that I
highly recommend. So now you have:
compelling reasons, a date of reference
and then on top of that you have found your
favorite platform. What is the next step?
So the next step is to build a very cool
profile because that's what people are
going to take a look at and based on
that they're going to make a decision
whether they want to have a language
exchange with you or not. A good profile
has to be compelling, short, simple,
possibly in two or three other languages
Remember: it's really important. So having
a good profile is fantastic but it's not
enough. People might contact you or
people might not contact you, so if
people don't contact you - which is
possible - you have to contact THEM, and in
that regard you have to send a very cool
message. I don't know if it has ever
happened to you that you were trying to
contact as many people as possible on
other platforms maybe and you created
the same stock message that you sent to
everybody. So, in that regard don't make
that mistake. What you should do is to
look into other people's profiles to
look for one or two details and then use
that as a hook, because that gives the
impression that you have actually read
the profile that you got interested in
that profile instead of sending the same
message to everyone remember the profile
building your own profile is important
but also sending people a compelling
message, a personal message is really
important to get into a cool connection.
So imagine that you send this cool
message, the person replied and you're
finally going to have your language
exchange. Now what do you want to do is
don't focus too much on the language, but
focus on communication, focus on
interaction, focus on cooperation. That's
what counts the most the first
impression is always the strongest and
the most important. So it's not about the
quantity of words, the cool expressions
that you use, the fact that you're using
the language but focus on speaking,
smiling, interacting, asking, being curious
when the person talks, listen attentively
that creates a very positive environment
and that is going to work wonders for
your language learning skills and his or
her language learning skills
Whatever happens, always make sure that
you record the conversation, this is
really important and it's easy to do
nowadays you can use a mobile phone
maybe your iPad, your computer, so whether
you have a conversation on the Internet
through Skype or other software programs
or you have an in real life, always make
sure that you have a recording device
with you. Remember recording the
information is really important because
later you can take a look at it you can
take a listen or again you can even see
it if you're recording video and that
will be really useful to further
memorize the information that is being
processed there. So here you have it: with
these six simple tips just get into a
language exchange, just jump into it
don't think about it too much and you
will see what an enormous difference it
can make it can be free, it can be
efficient, if you find the right language
partner you can do it on a weekly basis
maybe a couple of times a week - and if
you do it well and you find this good
environment, good positive environment of
cooperation, of stimulation of
inspiration, you will be able to do this
for a long time and it will work wonders
for your language
skills it will prepare you for real
conversations in real life. As always, I
have written an extensive article about
it and I read it out loud and I have
extra tips and video demonstrations
on the blog, so please click on the link
in the description box, head over the
blog and let's have a very constructive
and cool cooperation to build our language
skills in any language. So as usual, I
have one question and one cool tip. So
the question goes like this: have you
ever had a language exchange and what
are your best strategies when it comes
to communicating, interacting for example
through Skype or through another
software program, how did that go what
did you learn, what about your failures and
victories, please share all your stories
in the comment section below, I will be
more than happy to reply and hopefully
we can have a constructive conversation
we can learn from one another. So, time
for one final extra tip. Always make
sure that when you talk, when you get
your point across whatever you're
talking about the person who's listening
to you takes notes and writes down and
provides the feedback at the end of your
language exchange. In this way, you can
then take a look you can listen to the
recording and you can take a look at the
feedback that was given to you that was
that is written that you can actually
see and you can learn from it, so always
make sure that you go back to what you
did for the sake of learning because
when you take a look at it again without
having to speak because you're just
listening to the recording, you're
attacking the piece of information from
another angle, you're not stressed you
can just focus on learning and
extracting the information that was
given to you while you were talking. This
always makes a huge difference and if
you can, maybe reduce the amount of
language exchanges that you do twice a
week but always make sure that you
absorb the information later by
listening 48 hours after each language
exchange